this short little clip encompasses every
reason why dropshipping won't last
we know customers like low prices we
know customers like big selection and we
know that customers like fast delivery
and those things are going to be true 10
years from now they're gonna be true 20
years from now so we can count on those
things so we can put energy into them
how am I so sure drop shipping won't
last let's find out no I'm not gonna try
to sell you in a course or something at
the end
[Music]
I actually know some of the big
dropshippers in the space and most of
them are pretty good guys but I wanted
to provide a different perspective than
what every other online guru will tell
you before you go out and potentially
waste your money on drop shipping drop
shipping was one of the latest we'll
call it business ALPA box schemes that
has been around for a few years now this
is something that internet marketers
claim that if you buy their course
they'll teach you how a very little
effort you can make money quit your job
buy up new Lamborghini without much
effort because of this new opportunity
now that doesn't necessarily make these
business opportunities bad but this is
where things start getting a little
tricky the whole premise of dropshipping
is that you find these so-called winning
products from wholesale distributors
usually from China with Ollie express
then you set up an online store with
these products for sale at a marked up
price from the distributor without
having any actual inventory on hand then
you run paid ads to this product usually
on Instagram or Facebook and if someone
buys from you that's when you actually
order the product from the wholesale
distributor at a wholesale price the
product gets shipped directly to the
customer from the warehouse and the
benefit of this is that you don't need
any money to start and you don't have to
do any of the fulfillment whatsoever all
you have to do is find the product get
traffic to your website people buy and
you pocket the difference but this is
where this business model starts to fall
apart
[Music]
so what's wrong with dropshipping and
why won't it last well it's actually
pretty simple if you're able to answer
this one question where does money come
from when you get paid out a job you
made money because you provide a value
to your employer in the form of your
labor and in every other kind of
business on the face of the planet it's
the exact same story you make money from
customers when you provide enough value
to them the more value the more money
you make
so money can be looked at as just a
storehouse of value you get money when
you provide a value and you can use the
storehouse of value in the form of paper
in your wallet or digits in your bank
account to exchange it for other things
of value in the future like a new
Lamborghini so let's go back to a clip
of Jeff Bezos the richest man in the
world
we know customers like low prices we
know customers like big selection and we
know that customers like fast delivery
and those things are going to be true
ten years from now they're gonna be true
twenty years from now so we can count on
those things we can put energy into them
in Jeff's own words customers that buy
products online who would be potentially
buying your dropship products if you
were to start a drop shipping business
only care about these three things low
prices having a big selection and having
fast delivery and since those three
things are literally all Amazon focuses
on
that's probably why Jeff is the richest
man in the world because he's providing
more value to the world than anyone else
by building a worldwide infrastructure
of warehouses distribution centers
same-day delivery all what the goal of
keeping prices as low as possible with
the biggest selection as possible and
the fastest delivery as possible compare
that mindset to the only things people
focus on with drop shipping how can I do
the least amount of work how can I make
enough money to quit my job and fire my
boss oh it takes two to three weeks to
ship from China to the customer oh well
whatever it's not like customers care
about fast shipping or anything and
there lies the problem the entire idea
and business model of drop shipping
completely neglects what every customer
wants you will never have the lowest
prices since you're ordering one product
at a time from a warehouse that you have
no control over you're not gonna have
the biggest selection because all you're
focused on is finding that one
winning product and you're inherently
not gonna have the fastest delivery
because it's shipping directly from a
warehouse instead of a giant
custom-built infrastructure of
distribution centers like what amazon
has or in other words you literally
provide next to zero value to customers
besides the actual value of the product
itself which Amazon probably sells to at
a cheaper price with faster shipping
with better customer service when a
better return policy and the list just
goes on and on and on and because we
know money comes from providing value
since you don't provide much of value at
all you're probably not gonna make much
money so how are people making money
from lists lenten it's a reasonable
question with a few possible answers
whenever there's a new wave whether that
be mobile apps or the dot-com wave etc
the ones that are there first have such
a huge advantage that there's a
dedicated phrase for it the first
mover's advantage there's next to no
competition you have all the customers
to yourself and it's a lot easier to do
business and grow before the market
starts to get saturated I go over this
concept in my breakdown of the success
of pretty much the best tech channel on
YouTube marques Brownlee and it's a
pretty inspirational story so I'll link
it down below for you guys to check out
drop shipping was the same situation the
people who got there first were probably
able to advertise for cheap get their
valuable advertising data to market to
new customers a lot cheaper and more
efficiently increase their margins and
build a solid foundation before all
these new drop shippers came onto the
scene the next possibility is probably
more likely even though gurus might be
showing you huge sales numbers they
don't show you all their expenses how
much they spent on ads how much they pay
in taxes and what's really left over in
their pocket and I bet it's not very
much
any more depressing possibility that
100% happens is that people can just
fake their sales numbers it's as easy as
just editing the HTML in Chrome to
change the numbers taking a screenshot
on your phone and changing the numbers
in Photoshop using someone else's
account and there are a number of other
ways so how are people making money from
this then which one is it well like most
things in life is probably somewhere in
the middle you have those first movers
with an actual business you have the
ones that have super low margins and you
have the completely fake gurus that
literally just blatantly fake their
numbers but maybe I'm just being too
negative let's say you can make a
profitable honest drop shipping business
where you have enough profits to make it
worthwhile even if that is possible is
that really the best long-term business
model you want to get into where you're
kind of just doing it for the money not
because it's what's best for the
customers where you have major players
like Amazon who are concerned about
making a profit at all to snuff out the
competition in the long run and provide
as much of value to customers as
possible is this really the path you
want to go down so why are there so many
gurus on YouTube saying just how great
dropshipping is why is this ad you're
about to see probably about dropshipping
well you've probably guessed that but
selling online courses are one of the
most profitable business models out
there right now that really is hands-off
and definitely not like a saint putting
down online courses because this is
coming from personal experience too I
have a course on how I landed remote
jobs and even though it's a fraction of
the price drop shipping gurus are
selling their courses for it's still
ridiculously profitable like so
profitable to the point where I would be
pretty well-off if all I did was
shamelessly plug the course in every
single video I made but I personally
don't want to be that guy I don't want
to be selling all the time and telling
you that it's linked in the video
description and you should totally check
it out because I'm just not like that
but in all seriousness the ease and the
money and the lifestyle that
dropshipping promises is ironically more
in selling the courses themselves than
actually drop shipping
[Music]
I've been pretty negative about
dropshipping but is there any hope to it
at all is there any case for
dropshipping is actually a viable there
actually is even though the majority of
the time customers care most about low
prices big selection and fast delivery
there are other ways to provide value
and in turn have a successful drop
shipping business the reason why Apple
can sell their highest and I phone for
$1,300 and the airport's Pro for $250
when there are clearly more reasonable
options out there is because they're
selling the experience they're selling
the gratifying feeling you get when you
get to say Babla Bay they're successful
partly because of how superior you feel
compared to all the other clubs that
can't afford an iPhone and if you can
find a way to do the same with a drop
shipping store there might be some
promise in that or take the rise of
movement for example the popular
affordable watch brand although they're
really far away from just directly drop
shipping in the traditional sense I
would assume they still white label
their watches using existing
manufacturers with their own slightly
modified designs and they actually use a
Shopify store to host their website but
even though there are hundreds of other
watch brands out there they're so
successful because they found an
underserved niche affordable fashionable
watches and marketed it in a way where
you can still get away with some profit
margin yet still keep it affordable
enough to be successful and probably the
most realistic way I see dropshipping
being a viable business model is if you
already have a successful personal brand
for example if mr. beast open up a drop
shipping store with like fidget spinners
or something even though those aren't
popular anymore and he just snapped on
his logo he will probably make a lot of
money this is because people aren't just
buying it for the value of low prices
big selections or fast delivery they're
buying it because it's coming from you a
person that they're a fan of that they
trust and that they want to support in
fact there are many channels that make
an absolute killing whip merge dust drop
ships
well the merch is printed on the man
with someone orders and a ship directly
to loan from the
so is there any hope for dropshipping I
think my opinion can be summed up to
this whatever business you're going
after if all you're focused on is making
money in the easiest business
out-of-the-box way where you don't care
about the customer at all and you just
have this tunnel vision of making money
which is usually the mindset people go
into buying these courses unfortunately
you're gonna lose and you might as well
not start because at the end of the day
money comes from a generous standpoint
where you're willing to go the extra
mile to help out the customer not from
the position of I want to make money to
fire my boss so next time you see an ad
for whatever business opportunity comes
up just ask how much value does this
really provide to the world
thank you so much for being part of the
watch to the end Club what is your
experience and opinion on drop shipping
was this video like complete blasphemy
for you let me know down below because I
do read and reply to every single big
video I replied to every single comment
on my videos and if you are new to this
channel and you enjoy the style of like
visually pleasing videos for love
business entrepreneur niche be sure to
click that big red subscribe button down
below while you're down there as well
you can also turn on the notification
about to get notified whenever I release
a new video just like this one every
single week one last final plug you can
follow me on instagram i'm jake trent
io thank you so much for watching you've
been awesome I've been Jake I'll see you
guys in the next one
[Music]